we continue to do this for a total of K levels, what we find is that the error shrinks doubly exponentially in K. So we
don't need to do this very many times to make the error rate extremely small.
Meanwhile, the circuits are growing in size, but the size only increases singly exponentially in K because with each
level of fault tolerance, the size of our circuit grows by at most a factor that's determined by the maximum size of
our gadgets. And when it's all put together and an appropriate choice for the number
of levels of concatenation is made, we obtain the threshold theorem. But like I already suggested, there are a lot of details required to make this formal. So
what is this threshold value in reality? Well, it depends on the code and on the gadgets we
use for the steam code along with magic state distillation. It's minuscule and probably unlikely to be achievable in
practice. But using surface codes and state-of-the-art gadgets, it's been estimated to be around 1%. Which isn't
bad. And as new codes and methods are discovered, we can reasonably expect it to increase while simultaneously the
level of noise in the components we build will decrease. Reaching the point at which
large scale quantum computations can be implemented fault tolerantly will not be easy and it will not happen overnight.
But this theorem together with the advances in quantum codes and in quantum hardware that we've witnessed to date
provide us with the optimism that we need to continue to push forward to reach this ultimate goal of building a
large-scale fall tolerant quantum computer. And that is the end of the lesson and the end of the series. I
sincerely hope you found value in the series and if you have, please consider recommending it to a colleague or friend.
Also, be sure to check out IBM Quantum Learning for additional courses and tutorials, and subscribe to the Qiskit
YouTube channel if you haven't already, so you can stay uptodate with our future content releases. Thank you for
watching.